a warning delivered from the heart of
government
the coveted threat escalated to level
four
hundreds of possible daily deaths
transmission rising
exponentially but these men striding
towards downing street
are scientists not politicians their
evidence
is about to impact us all by mid-october
you would end up with something like 50
000 cases
in the middle of october per day
50 000 cases per day would be expected
to lead a month later so the middle of
november say
to 200 plus deaths per day
hospital admissions are rising older
patients are becoming infected
it's why millions of people across the
country are already living under local
restrictions
but this could be just the start of a
long
and difficult few months so we have in a
bad sense
literally turned a corner although only
relatively recently
and we i think everybody will realize
that at this point the seasons are
against us
we should see this as a six-month uh
problem that we have to deal with
collectively uh it's not indefinite
yes
the warning from downing street is that
the virus is not getting weaker
these words will resonate in hospitals
and waiting rooms across the country
this gp surgery was overwhelmed in march
of course they're going to be much
better prepared this time around but for
the doctors and staff who work here it's
somewhere
they just don't want to go back to and
tell me how long that's been going on
for
dr vinish patel has already seen a huge
rise
in suspected covet 19 cases
we've seen an increase in the patients
who are contacting us with symptoms that
we
typically see during the winter but
obviously a lot of those symptoms
overlap with covid
and so the demand for seeing them
testing them
um giving them reassurance has increased
massively the scary thing now is that
we're heading into the winter months
so all the problems that we faced back
in march it feels that it's
ten times worse now what we're asking
for is not to rush into anything
the scientific community is polarized a
letter signed by some of the country's
leading doctors
including professor carol sakura has
been sent to the prime minister
it urges a targeted approach instead of
a sweeping lockdown
there's also another scenario where it's
much much less
what we didn't hear today was that the
number of people becoming ill
and going to hospital has dropped right
down
scientists usually steer clear of
talking about the economic impacts of
lockdown
today though there was an acceptance
that finding a balance
would be challenging ministers making
decisions
and all of society have to walk this
very difficult balance
if we do too little this virus will go
out of control
and we will get significant numbers of
increase direct and indirect deaths
but if we go too far the other way then
we can cause damage
to the economy the scientists
can only advise ultimately
what happens next is down to the
politicians
ashish joshi sky news